[Music]
you dare enter this house
bad [__] you you don't know
what you got yourself into I have mad
flavor here your favorite [__] that I'm
gonna help you out with your day it's
Thursday
you got a whole hump maybe don't get
paid till tomorrow why should I leave
the house cuz you gotta leave the house
[__] that's why because the
note man don't suck around I'll be Joey
don't suck around and you shouldn't be
[__] around
we're back [__]
Thursday mornings I think it's March
time whatever the [__] it is don't
matter no matter if it's [__] Jew 38
you're still a bad [__] all you
leave is maybe just to get settled you
gotta put the guy back into your guard
and start working all over again
understand me but to help you out we got
death today you see a label that means
[__] deadly
and a nice time last night the hawk cafe
Bryan Callen Tommy Easter for 20 at
least I got [__]
Tommy Easter comes on this [__]
for 20 every day I suggest you hang out
with Tommy's he's the disciple of the
church these make yourself you gonna
wreck yourself there's big fixing ass is
badly a mother's [__] exam
but enough with the chitty-chat it's
time to check out the goods understand
is that the end of the day after your
doing you don't live with the goods
whether it's dick whether it's love
whether it's helping somebody out you're
delivering the [__] goods on a
daily like Judas Priest and 70 [__]
ain't how bent hell bent for leather
you know what time is it's time for
another [__] bowl because this was
empty understand we don't stand there
looking at me like chili another bowl it
stirs me I got I've talked to people
don't give a [__]
maybe it's best that you own their stone
for the guilty you its reefer that's
right [__] we rewrote the
tequila solitaire
it's refund even the Mexicans are
jumping on board
tequila ain't making no money the cartel
there's some tank eat the reefer
bowl number two what have you done today
[__] don't say
so it's Thursday so what may be the
width employers planned [__] smoke
out the round and you come back one day
stronger quicker faster and with a
bigger dick that's all that matters
member you come back next week with a
bigger thing okay today might not be
your lucky day
it is your lucky day and you choke the
[__] but it's not [__] you go
home eat some vegetables smoke some
really looking for push-ups and boom
you're back Michael [__] Simone sure
San Jose tonight 8 o'clock review there
bring reefer don't come up the end and
I'm saying at least couple of [__]
lighter my girl Jenny will be there my
boys will Scooby's hermanos will be
there
the Birdman Jaime Acosta be there cuz
he's a bad [__] and I suggest
you're there too there's gonna be at
least 20 2.2 pounds of different exotic
reefers from all over the [__]
continent general cypher joy what should
the chitter chatter what should the
[__] ear beaten on Thursday smoke that
[__] you're absolutely right
it's a beautiful day to smoke a little
reefer with my family the job my [__]
family not farming if I were the [__]
Borgata you know saying that's what we
owe
wait there should we smoke another one
yes crocodile Uncle Joe why you being
such a [__] [__] today stairs dick
you're absolutely right my little
nephews it's time to smoke another
because it game gonna roll with three
what the [__]
three two legs a big big equal three
girl Sam oh [__]
go pull it where it compiler whoever
will take us I leave my app I'm a little
bit but they're singing we're with whom
they don't have any business that don't
care see like you getting it go ahead
turn up in down my take on my mother is
Eloy boy I see my mom a loco horny
weather book I'm a man wrong car being
honest with you there are some busy work
are exploring you know myself movie
ended me see can be given to my mom and
I think that all of them or say no no
son gonna [__] cancer
yeah that's right you [__]
that's how we do it
a little spit the rude language for you
[__] maybe you learn some maybe
you don't but next time you see some
nice man is gay hey uncle Joey told me
my pinga and there you go you're him
like [__] Flint and give me a Cuban
sandwiches you read the fried bananas
you know
you know why because you guys are my
Bonnie nice Maya serious that's what it
there's a straight line more in Cuba I
don't know how about wanna they took me
more Nina means my [__] my dog I said
hey you know these [__] you but
until kill me I'll say I'm gonna do a
bump you want to take a beat they don't
let them know passive I am bossy see the
overlap is a little spectrum I listen
it's in the Spanish Ashok poems get your
[__] prick you can't do deck with
shell clones but you can always do some
with Spanish and I'm saying because they
have you ain't friends with the Busboys
you ain't dick when I go to West one
don't worry about the waiter mind the
Busboys called queenly to the love and
respect he deserves
yes in the class is always filled this
role was as Brendon uncle Joey does
[__] cuz you got to give love to
everybody okay
beside that as you know I see
[__] San Jose I'm strong to the
gills
[Music]
than what you think I'd affinage the
bowl it
[Music]
I'm a [__] slob bingo you know
there's a big noise [__] sack like
some [__] spec servicemen and say
people shopping pilot toy you see and do
but anyway as usual any day and if they
had a week seven twenty four I love you
[__] as you know I have no
money and not bad and therefore [__]
family you guys are my family when did
we become family would you say you dumb
[__] can't family first time we
smoked the ball and did one of these
[__] things maybe you come to a show
maybe you broke the whatever the [__]
give me a hug I'm good dog I'll give you
a hug you gotta put the owner in and
don't come up to me with [__] onion
our [__] this we're gonna have a
dissolution you don't say but anyway
it's Thursday be the best you could be
don't take [__] from nobody
not then not even a [__] they should
have stopped hitting and mewling don't
take [__] from nobody you bad
[__] today grab your [__] brush
your hair brush your teeth and get out
there you don't give a [__]
things don't go your way you go home you
wipe off you go to bed you get another
shot tomorrow right I see your
[__] ass a nose L not the
church Monday night oh yeah they didn't
get my might then I pinged our a sorry I
love you [__] State Blackman
salad